Mark Cartier is a Hollywood producer and
writer he has worked on many big
projects check his AMD be out you'll
have seen his work and he very kindly
and graciously agreed to come on to my
channel to discuss Star Trek Stargate
and lots of other things you might know
him though is the geek from the shuttle
pod show
now I thought I'd only chat with Mark
for about an hour we ended up chatting
for over two so I've split the video
into two halves here's part one
thank you
[Music]
but this to me it's like I started doing
this Channel about two years ago now but
I've only really recently started like
talking to real people yeah and and I
still I'm not very good at it so
so we're just gonna have a chat you have
I tell this to Conor and Dominic all the
time and I don't want to blow the good
stuff before the show but
um they have the Charisma and the draw
Power I have the nerdum and and Erica
is hot
so I think that's like one two three we
have it all I was I think I was watching
you have the nerdum you've got the
brains and the you know I'm not
charismatic what no you're also
charismatic and you draw a giant
audience
um I think
um the thing I get told by by people
that do quite like what I do
um but she's not everybody but because
it's just that I'm I'm excitable and um
I obviously enjoy what I'm talking about
and I'm like well if I can get that
across then
I'm winning really yeah yeah so I love
it um so yeah when because I've seen
that I mean you're the the shuttle pod
shows what for two years old now three
years old no
um we started in
we started a test shoots and we shot our
first episode in February and March of
last year
all right
it was an experiment and uh I went off
to produce a movie called glorious
uh and the show took a five month Hiatus
while I was producing the movie they
actually made a couple episodes without
me
and then uh when I came back we I was I
was looking at the numbers and I was
like I'm willing to quit my job running
this big Entertainment Company
and uh dedicate myself full time to
producing the shuttlebot June if you
guys are willing to give me the year or
two to grow it
to a place where it can actually
you know pay us like adults uh and they
were
they were on board so we've really only
been doing this full time since uh
November December
this most recent not like someone's
season two
started would it be yeah yeah exactly
Season Two started with us deciding that
this was going to be full time
because I mean that's a very different
style to the first scene it's very
yeah different it's an obvious
transition between the two
um a lot of that just comes with it not
being a weekend Hobby and actually being
my full-time job
yeah I I was very lucky that about uh
not if January just gone I was able to
go down to four days a week on my proper
job thanks to this channel yeah it's
amazing I I actually started my channel
I had I like a history and conspiracy
Channel at first just because
um yeah I went through a really oh yeah
oh God it was a nightmare but um I went
uh I did it for three years and I
finally got monetized three years it
took
um and but I learned how to do this
um but I only did it because I I used to
work nights and I had nothing to do
during the day when my wife and
everyone's at her at school and stuff
and I was like I've got to do something
or I'm going to get up to Mischief so I
did a YouTube channel
um gardening wasn't scratching the itch
well I kept killing stuff so
that's like normal I'm really good at
digging holes I can dig a hole all day
but I meant to do but um but yeah then I
dropped that just because I got really
bored of being
um threatened and things like this
because I would talk about messages I
love stores that's my thing I love this
story yeah so I would talk about these
things and then some people just come on
and go you're a liar or you're a shill
or you're being paid for by and I
actually got threatened the aluminum
hats would come in and oh yeah
oh yeah but it's the what it killed it
when somebody actually tried to start
messaging my wife and started haven't I
got my wife so that was just like right
this is done there
um but I started this side track Channel
and got monetized in three weeks so um
I'm just better at this but anyway so
how are you actually finding
having a YouTube channel trying to grow
it I mean I know you've got you've got
Connor and you've got Dominic which is a
bonus that helps having people that
actually know but
how are you find it because it's not
easy
uh it is not this is one of the hardest
things
um
I've ever done uh it's grueling it is
absolutely to do it
do it the right way it is absolutely a
full-time job and to our show
I think that
we need like 12 full-time staff members
to do our show the right way and we have
you know me
[Laughter]
yeah we've got an uh an editor who is
largely full-time but um you know also
does other gigs
uh
yeah uh we've got a number of of
volunteers and and part-time people we
just don't have the revenue yet to to
have the staff so it's it's a lot more
grueling than I thought it would be um
to build it from the ground up because
normally my uh experience has been you
go
you set up a movie you have the package
this is what it's going to cost here's
the budget you get the money you shoot
the movie you deliver it you move on to
the next thing yeah um this is the first
time where it's like
we have to start from Ground Zero with
no no
um investor no you know and just grow an
audience grow Revenue it's it's totally
different experience it's it's very
challenging it's a lot of fun and the
community is the big surprise
uh I love the community so much but um
uh you know giving the members of the
community the attention that they
deserve and
um maintaining that that sort of
interaction with Community yeah and
uh then also dealing with some of the
negative elements you know the people
who get angry at you because you said
the wrong buzzword and it somebody said
the wrong thing in an interview
wrong you don't have to do anything
we talked about uh guns because Connor
we had a speaking of Stargate which is
you know uh your jam we did uh
uh Joe Flanagan recently and Joe and
Connor and I all grew up with guns I had
a gun certification when I was 13 years
old
um all of us grew up with guns we
respect and admire guns as tools uh and
you know we were just kind of talking
about it and what it's like to grow up
when we grew up uh I can't imagine
I think we were talking about it because
my son who is 13
is you know uh has a gun and you know
we're talking about gun safety for him
and it's like what a different world it
is now and
uh the amount of vitriol we've received
from both sides like how dare you talk
about guns or evil or how dare you
on guns uh it's our secretary yeah
exactly it's like I grew up with guns
what do you talk about no one said
anything negative about guns also no one
said anything promoting guns in some
sort of extreme
rights way
we all grew up with them and we have a
healthy respect for them and the last
two weeks have been just mountains of
anger on both sides of it and that just
it shocks me it didn't that didn't even
occur to me that the people get angry
but I very occasionally will actually
share an opinion on something and woke
is the thing I get the most grief oh God
yeah um we have a tree on our show an
avocado tree called wash named after the
pilot from Firefly wash uh
yes yes you and I are going to be
friends what's
the actor's name yes
um
so we've been call it's Washington I've
been calling him he we've been calling
him he for like a year
ever since we named him and uh Conor
made a joke uh this last week he said oh
they them or something and he was just
being lighthearted about it and
and holy did we get we've gotten
messages we've gotten postcards and our
post office box the comment section
exploded like stand your lane
don't Ram your Hollywood politics down
our throats and it's like what are you
talking about
bleeds into it a little bit relevant
culture bleeds into it like at some
point though you do just want to go in
capitals it's a f in avocado tree yeah
it's in a avocado tree
um
we own an avocado tree that's what you
should never go to Silver
I have this like
disappointment in people for feeling so
bold
on the internet
yeah you would never say that to my face
if you were standing in front of me in
the street
or in front of like your mother
you would never say that so why are you
why do you think it's okay to say it
here
um why don't you have the same respect
and courtesy and politeness that you
have when you're in front of your own
mother or your grandmother or your
children yeah it's not okay to behave
this way just because you're on the
Internet it's one thing to share your
your opinion everybody's opinion is
valid and I'm that's open Discord is the
basis of you know democracy and blah
blah blah but
you know just to be an because
you're on the internet is really
disappointing
um yeah I've got a nemesis it's great
um it's um I've just got a guy that
every video I do he has to comment and
it has to be something that I've done
wrong or said wrong or I'm a liar
because I've I'll do a video saying well
there's this rumor
oh okay I gotta get that a lot
um and there's this room where I've
heard I don't believe it but I will tell
you guys because it's come from this
place or whatever
um and it's interesting
um well you're a liar because well now
because I told you one I didn't believe
it and two I told you where it came from
it didn't come from me and you know it's
like but you know
um but you know people are very brave
but you know it's quite fun having a
nemesis
um he just go too far sometimes and I've
blocked him once or twice early on and
then he'd reappear
um as something else and I just gave up
and then I just thought you know what
actually he keeps commenting he keeps
clicking keeps watching the videos yeah
yeah oh that's a really good point
um our the people who on us the
most in our comments and on our social
medias and everything every single week
they're back with another angry comment
so I think they're just addicted to it
yeah thank you Mr algorithm okay thank
you phone calling also I kind of um you
know it was a little
it there are a couple of times where it
it was really
um overwhelming
like surprisingly negative and it sort
of shocked me and I I was like why am I
doing this why are we doing this
collectively yeah uh but then um I
somebody reminded me that engagement
is Big points for the algorithm yeah so
you know if you consider
controversial negative blah blah blah
um and you have people fans of the show
defending it uh that's engagement and
it's just like change change every time
someone comments
and I thought all right well if I just
treat it as publicity
yeah you're never going to please
everyone sure I mean I did a video
talking about Enterprise actually and
then I said um Scott
um bacula
and and then I got a million comments
saying it's Scott Bakula like Dracula
back Jack yeah
and I think I said Bakula
um I don't think I've ever heard him say
his name before but actually then
somebody commented because I went oh
yeah I'm so sorry I pinned the comments
and yes okay I said it wrong and
somebody said just now love it you
should make a mistake in every single
video because you'll get loads of
comments yeah
missed saying people's names wrong but
yeah so that's what I've learned about
YouTube is that uh you have to
you have to you have to work the
algorithm
yeah and ignore you have to have a thick
skin not take any of the negativity
personally and then you know I encourage
uh Conor and Dominic and Erica to stay
out of the comments
just because like I want them to have
fun when the camera's on I I can take it
um I don't care you can say whatever you
want about me
um
where I get upset is when people get uh
pointedly violent or negative or assholy
um on individuals like other fans
or our guests or our hosts
you know like in a personal way that's
where I get agitated but otherwise
whatever that like I said that's when I
killed the conspiracy channel is when
they start some idiot tries to drop my
wife into it and I'm just sort of like I
forgot me I'm the one that said it don't
you know it's just ridiculous
um I I really like your channel because
one of the reasons is it's a it's a fun
chat I will be honest with you I only
found it when you did the Dominic blue
video
um somebody yeah literally a couple of
weeks ago and I've now just watched oh
the David blue
um yeah also David blew I said Dominic
blue didn't know David
[Music]
um
that's great
um so but I like that it's really like
it's like friends is that around a thing
having a chat it's friendly yeah they do
the one of the things I really like
about Conor and Dominic though as well
that I've I've spoken to actors before
at Comic Cons and things and you assume
you very quickly realize they don't
actually have a clue about a show they
appeared in
um yeah
yeah
they they really do know
and I would say that acting and I
apologize for interrupting you uh this
internet thing there's always that yeah
um
uh I will say acting is a very hard job
it's very very hard it's hard enough to
work 16 hours a day and know your lines
Felicity requirements yeah you it's you
don't have a life if you have a family
oh my God like
uh I don't want to say I don't want
anyone to get angry here's everyone's
gonna get angry because it's like it's
not the same as being shipped off to war
but it's similar in
um it's incredibly intense uh it it
takes you away from anything that
resembles a life and puts you through
this thing this this mission that you
have to achieve which is to deliver
episode after episode after episode
um
and uh you know at a certain point it's
you just can't immerse yourself in what
you're making you oh yeah the only thing
it's everything you have just to know
your lines
I don't blame any active for doing that
it's a job and then they're playing a
part but it is nice to see
actors and and a lot of the visitors
you've had to actually do
no I mean Connor seems to be able to
even he knows everything so they're
asking the question oh the episode with
the blah blah and the thing yeah and
Dominic as well he's just uh Dominic
knows all the character names and the
things he really picked it up let's see
doing this show and they say this a lot
during our show I don't know how many of
our episodes you've seen but
um in the beginning it was obvious that
they didn't know a lot about Star Trek
but
in the process of making this show uh
and building our community around the
show they have had to re-engage with
Star Trek in a way that they'd never had
to do it before they're actually
watching the episodes because when we
have a guest on they want to be able to
watch a bunch of their episodes and have
an understanding of who the character
was and the challenges of that character
challenges of the time you know you you
talk about
um the fact that our show is like a
conversation uh when we originally
designed the show and started test
shooting
it was designed to be a sort of
uh combination
uh
insert your big name Star Trek podcast
here slash The Tonight Show with you
know Johnny Carson you know like a talk
like a
talk show
um and when we we the first test that we
shot
I played myself as a Star Trek fan
uh and they just interviewed me just to
kind of see where they're what their
where their chops were and the
conversation just seemed like a three
friends because we all know each other
Connor and I have known each other for a
long time
uh
it just and we've gone through a lot of
similar life issues uh together like
almost at the same time and
it uh it just seemed like three friends
talking around a campfire
sharing stories about this adventure
that they had all had in you know
Hollywood over the last 20 years and it
struck me that that's what we need to do
uh when we interview Star Trek people
all of them have fought in the same War
they have the same Adventure 20 years
ago and they're friends because they
have a shared experience even if even if
they're if they haven't been over to
each other's houses or anything
you know they're all they all went to
the same they all had the same adventure
together
I think so often my friends through sort
of conventions
that comes up a lot we've sat in this
hotel room
yeah and a lot of friendships have
sparked up because of the show as well
which is really exciting
um
so how did the show then get started and
what was the who thought of it first
what where did you
why didn't do that uh I was supposed to
go produce a couple of movies in New
York so I was in the middle of moving to
New York City and um
the pandemic happened
and got locked down a month before I was
supposed to move to New York and uh
immediately the first movie I was
working on
died and then the second one died
uh and I happen to be working with uh
uh someone at the time Consulting and
they because of the way things were uh
they just hired me to run their company
it was in a european-based investment
firm who had some
American
properties uh so I was managing a
distribution catalog
for motion picture distribution and
acquisition and production and
you know for like a year I was by myself
on the sixth floor of this building in
Burbank and uh uh I you know I watched
everyone start doing podcasts and
everyone's doing things from home and
I'd always wanted to do a Star Trek show
or
you know something like a YouTube show
just before
and Connor and I because Connor and I
had to go through covet testing like
almost every week because of our jobs in
the industry
um
we would hang out with each other
because there was no one else to hang
out with
uh and we would play a lot of pool and
he said he told me a story about I
started talking about the Delta flyers
and he said oh that's funny because I
talked to Garrett Wong recently and he
had
he was like uh this is this is how we
started it and it's what we're doing and
you know you should do a show
and I was like stop talking we're doing
a show if you're even a little
interested we're gonna do a Star Trek
show and I'm gonna produce it and I
promise you I'll produce the balls out
of it and he was like all right
so we spent a couple of months throwing
ideas around and trying to pull it
together and then um once we had a
better idea of what we're doing we uh
got Dominic involved and
um you know we started doing some test
shoots and
uh I would run around try and tell them
what they're really good at and ignore
the things that they were really bad at
just not do those things again and
oh God I wish that somebody telling me
it was good
you have the YouTube comments page
oh yeah no if I did that though I'd
throw myself up a bridge I mean um and
I'd probably have people cheering but
you know uh Ira Stephen bear said it
best uh you can't listen to the fans
um
uh you have to write episodes for
yourself not for that yeah I would do
stuff for me fans one
things that are they want Space Battles
and they want no conflict they want you
know and they all want different things
so if you it's and now and just by
saying this out loud a bunch of people
are going to say everyone should listen
to the fans Terry metallis listen to the
fans and look what happened with card
season three uh Star Trek in a bit
because I've got opinions on that but
yeah and I I would say you know that's
not exactly what he meant uh he meant
you know if you don't come from an
honest place and care about the
characters that you're writing for uh
and about the franchise you're writing
for and give it
um real uh Primal conflict uh that in
which the the the characters can grow
and or learn or get beaten down or the
people that you care about have to
struggle or you will stop caring about
them
um that's just human nature so I agree
with that we can't we can't do this
we do this for our fans but we can't do
it for our fans like no if that makes
every stuff that you love first
yeah I think it comes across if you
don't uh I I I've been tempted I
actually think and you know again I
don't mean interrupt but I I actually
think one of the reasons that our show
works is because I am a fan first
um I am such a huge Star Trek fan and
whenever we struggle with the best
choice to make it's like well what would
I want to watch
oh yeah because it makes it easy it
makes it fun yeah
and I just think if it's fun for me I
mean I've I've had phases where it's
become work I remember the first time I
had a video that did really really well
yeah and was chasing clicks and I was so
I was trying to do what can I do that
again yeah and then you know they don't
and they're like oh crap and I just I
just thought no remember what you said
when you first started doing it do stuff
I want to do
and other people will like it and if
other people don't like it don't matter
yes a perfect example of that mentality
is we were struggling to determine
what a a release time was
when were we going to post our videos
and at first it was like well let's try
to post them on Sundays what time does
it matter whatever we'll just they'll be
live people will watch them that was
before we understood that um a regular
schedule was pretty important and then
when we decided to do this full time
when we launched season two we started
we decided that we would start doing
live chat premieres where we would
uh promo it and and have it go live at
10 a.m Sunday morning and uh anyone who
came could chat with us we'll be in the
chat room we can watch the episode
together we'll make an event out of it
um and that really grew our Channel
quickly
um
that really helped out and but we were
struggling with what time what day all
that and people were like you can't do
it this day because of that show you
can't do it this day because of that
show you can't do it this way because
people in the UK are still working and
it's like go to sleep yeah or something
it's like there's no way we're not gonna
ever get the whole world awake when
we're doing it uh right now Australia is
like two or three in the morning when we
do it which is a bummer because
Australia is a really great fan base for
us but uh you know
Germany is bigger the UK is bigger uh
and so uh I just chose Sunday morning at
10 because it's like we've been working
all week and I would really like a
mimosa
and I'd like to sleep the rest of my
Sunday because I haven't slept between
when we record the show which is
Wednesdays or Thursdays and then we
release it on Sunday
um
uh and everyone was concerned about that
and I said listen if there's no way
we're going to find a perfect time slot
there's no way we're gonna not go up
against somebody else who does a good
Star Trek show uh we just have to do our
own thing
uh and if we do a good show people will
watch it if I'm doing something terrible
they won't watch it
um you know we want to be supportive of
the other great Star Trek shows that are
out there and the community at large but
you know
you gotta do you first and yeah
you gotta put your stake in the ground
and put up your sign and say here's our
here's what we're doing if you want to
be a part of it you know where we are it
was an easy choice for me because you
know you've got the algorithm that tells
you when people when most fans are on
sort of like oh my fans come on about
six o'clock in the evening
we get our most views on noon on Mondays
I think which is a weird thing I'll say
I I try not to think about it too much I
got a a guy that that's one thing I love
going to say about the community I've
made genuine friends doing this a couple
of them are join me on my shows and I do
a live show on a Sunday
um I got my pal stormings in American I
just I just got talking to him through
this like again doing the conspiracy
Channel this live Harris I want to be
actor in LA and we started talking and
it's now he's on every week and a pilot
lives just down the road in Dudley it's
about half an hour away and like I
didn't know any of these people and now
they're genuine friends absolutely it's
amazing
we've made genuine friends through this
show not just on the crew side our crew
have turned into family
um and then you know friends the a bunch
of our guests have like hung around and
become friends we pal around we go grab
a drink or whatever
um
the uh but we've made
I personally have made really close
friends through making this show just
people who found us early and were fans
of our show and especially when we did
our live event in February and a bunch
of people sort of self-organized and
said you clearly need help
we want to help you
let's get a resume call and we will help
you with the Manpower and you know and
they they self-describe themselves as
the uh the wash gang uh after our
avocado tree and uh uh yeah I mean
there's some they're all I consider all
of them close personal friends now
um they're people that I rely on when
you know when the things are rough or
there's an issue behind the scenes and I
need some help getting the word out that
this or that there's a schedule swap or
yeah yeah does anyone know how to make
an Excel spreadsheet that does blah yeah
I've had to do that with choices so well
it's not the one lab that's luckily he's
an I.T nerd he's a complete so he can do
all my computer stuff but I just don't
know how to do because you want to do a
Discord server I don't know what that is
yes should we have one he's like yes we
shall I can hook it up and do all the
videos can go in there on my excellent
we can put our videos on Discord
well he's he's put us on there so I
don't know what happens I occasionally
will bug me go will you please go on
Discord and at least say hello to
somebody fine still don't know what it
is I'm making a note of that yeah we
have a Discord serving it and our guy's
gonna do because he's created like a
Minecraft thing as well that you can go
in there and it's like a Sidetrack
Minecraft server and no clear what that
is but um but yeah you do some great
stuff but uh we had a lady actually we
had nobody on our Facebook group which
could not get people to join the
Facebook group at all and then this lady
Shelley just went I'll sort it out for
you and within a month we had like 2 000
people on there oh yeah
oh thank you yeah it's something like 80
Facebook blah blahs and then somebody
else started doing it and now we're over
3 000 and it's like okay yeah I'm about
to really know how to do it no I didn't
I didn't have a clue I just don't ask
people on the channel but she just went
no and she just shares it like crazy and
so yeah you have to get on there and do
it and talk and comment and and you know
just have conversations with people it's
the only way to make any of this grow
I've noticed that on all of our
everywhere we are you know we have a I
have a schedule I get on Twitter and
spend 40 minutes on Twitter just
sharing and liking and commenting and
engaging and blah blah
I should do that more I keep getting
into arguments on Twitter so I should
probably stay off there oh I avoid
arguments all together I try to I try to
make jokes a lot yeah
I tried I was agreeing with somebody
who's talking about AI today and I was
agreeing with him and he still had a go
at me I'm just like dude I'm agreeing
with you stop attacking me but um he was
angry but he actually works in the
industry and he's just freaking out
about everything's going on at the
moment and his
argument is like let's just ban all AI
it's just not allowed in the industry at
all we just gotta ban it all and I'll
start saying I'm not sure
some of the smartest people on the
planet have said it's too late it's
happening it's done we have to
deal with it and if we don't we're
morons and uh uh it's going to be hard
and hopefully we reach some sort of
Utopia State as a result of it but it's
already done it's there's no stopping it
it's too late that was basically my
argument I said we need to regulate it
we need to it would be nice to actually
try to do something before a foreseeable
problem happens once with technology
instead of like reacting later so that
would be good
but other than that we it's it's too
late not human nature
come on Jay it's not the history of
existence taught us anything we're gonna
wait until the bad thing happens and
then we're gonna overreact
yeah or sometimes we underreact and then
something even worse happens to me but
that that's what I like history and I
just made the point of like um you know
when Motorcars came along the the people
with horses freaked out or what about my
horse and it's not the same because
we're like companies like what about our
feed stable in downtown San Francisco
yeah technology has been putting people
out of work forever but it always seems
to you know figure itself out and it
always creates more jobs because
generally somebody has to take care of
the thing that's replacing the thing
yeah but yeah
let's just hope that sorts itself out
soon because um you know I want Stargate
to come back and I think yeah I think
that's one of the things holding it up
at the moment so please Amazon please
just announce it I beg of you
um when you've had some of the people on
there because obviously you said you
were a Trekkie so you were you were a
Star Trek fan
some of the actors on there then if you
I mean did you did you know people like
Robert picardo beforehand or or do you
get a bit because I'd be Starstruck as
hell I actually I met uh Nathan Fillion
recently and I just sat there and went
Nathan at him for about five minutes and
and and I didn't I couldn't get my words
out I had all these clever things I was
going to ask him and I just went Nathan
Nathan yeah
um it was it was awful
um
um does that happen to you guys I mean I
mean obviously I thought Dominic and and
and kind of know them already a lot of
the time but
I've been around the this industry for a
very long time uh and I have worked with
some of the biggest celebrities in the
world and
uh when I was in my early 20s I worked
for a producer called David Foster who
has uh passed away recently uh he was a
mentor of mine
and he taught me a lot of what I know
about this business and one of the
things he taught me is that
um you can never get sucked into a
celebrity's Vortex because then things
go bad
you have to be their boss
remember you are their boss they don't
work unless you hire them or you create
something for them to do uh and uh
you also have to remember that uh the
quarterback isn't the only person on
your team you own the entire football
team yeah uh and so you've got an entire
team of players that require you to be
their boss as well so you know when
you're ass kissing the quarterback the
other the other team members are not too
happy about that so
um I've always been pretty good at not
getting Star Struck
sometimes I do
you know when Jonathan Frakes walked
into the room for the first time I was
like holy
big fella as well
charismatic he just exudes Charisma in
in front of him you know
it's like the barometer changed when
when he pulled up
um there have been some uh
uh guests that we had where I was like
it's not too much and I I kept it under
unchecked
I'm such a Star Trek nerd yeah like I
mean I had Brent Spina on here I would
just giggle all the way through it yeah
and um and he liked the post I put on
they put they they put a photo on his
thing and it was um Jonathan Frakes
I think it's Marina certis and somebody
else I forget who the other person was
and then they're like cooking and
Brent's spine is just behind with a
glass of wine but he just looks like
three friends with the serial killer
just behind him about to attack and
that's what it looked like so I made the
comment and he liked it and I was like
best day ever
since they're fun
exciting things about the all this
modern technology is you know you
get to actually engage with the people
that you whose work you respect uh
um how rewarding is that for us
uh to have a bit of a smaller world and
you know get to get to say thank you to
the people whose work we appreciate yeah
yeah exactly exactly yeah and you
haven't acknowledged well yeah Brad
Wright who created Stargate yeah yeah he
actually he followed my channel on my
birthday this year just oh happy
birthday that's awesome yeah my wife was
buying me a gift and I'm just like
whatever you buy me it's not going too
um well I'm a huge fan of his he doesn't
follow me yet but hopefully he will I
have I have I'm conspiring to do a
Stargate something and I have I have
been for the last six six to 12 months
can you talk about that or because we do
quite like Stargate on this channel
I don't know if it's okay I put you on
the spot there but I didn't know you
were going to say that yeah I didn't
know I was gonna say it either I'm such
a big so Star Trek is my big that's my
show
um
Stargate
Firefly
uh Battle Star those are
all right in line and uh
you know uh I've always I if
if I'll tell you what when you do your
Stargate project come back and tell us
about it
oh I'm so excited too I would be love I
would love to do that cool I'm really
excited about it because it seems like
we've been taking the first steps
recently to pull it together
um cool you know I don't know if you
watched the Joe Flanagan interview but
maybe re-watch that one
um I don't know uh how how much you paid
attention to the David blue interview
but maybe you should re-watch that one I
did I've watched it
I am
I've basically built the channel on
Stargate rumors and things and that's
that's all I've been talking about I was
very good Target News Channel I've been
watching your stuff yeah well we track
Student News I was uh so that's why I
was so well
I saw our show on your and that's how we
started talking as I saw our show on
your channel because I think it was you
were doing a review you were you were
doing an analysis of Joe Flanagan's
interview
and uh I thought it was well done and I
was like oh this guy's great I have to
know this guy
yeah when you messaged me after admit I
did I was thinking oh I'm gonna get told
off
but you're nice about it so I was like
great well I mean I the thing I love
about Joe's interview and again you guys
he's chatting thing but he was just so
honest and it was nice to hear it yeah
and a genuine opinion and it just came
across a genuinely stung in when SGU got
um cancer SGA got canceled sorry and
that came across and again it's just
like
again I'd kill to talk to everyone again
if you want me to kill anyone and and
get one hit I will do it
um because he's just he and he was
always my favorite character maybe David
I did love David Hewlett loved me but um
shows fantastic and Joe is uh Joe's one
of the guests that we've had on a show
that has stuck around that we I
um Conor and Joe are very good friends
and Joe and I have been talking a lot uh
and uh
I have you know
I have a feeling Joe's gonna be around a
lot
good well that would be great because
we'd love to see more of it because
again it's just I mean the fans love him
he's such a great guy go ahead he's
talking about
yeah I'm just like God I love this guy
sort of a bee with this guy
um and you don't always have that you
know opinion some some actors are very
up themselves or whatever and I think
you've got I think it's got to be an ego
part for you to want to do this apart
but he doesn't come across like that he
just comes but and he genuinely seemed
to love SGA so obviously the fans adore
Joe
um
and you know he actually tried to he
really did try to save the show again so
I mean the fans are just gonna he can do
whatever he likes
if he turned him I know ever what
they're what they're talking about like
none of them are in the room none of
them know what decisions it's all
speculative and it's all it's all
um
I mean it's all passion based it's for
the love of the show or the franchise or
whatever uh and you know they're they're
justifiable and they're it's Justified
that they have strong emotions to a show
being canceled or whatever
um Prodigy is being has been canceled in
in Star Trek fans are up in a riot and
it's like Prodigy was great I get why
they're upset
uh but you know of the other negativity
around that conversation it's like this
is
they didn't cancel because everyone
they didn't cancel it because they were
making boatloads of money they canceled
it because they couldn't afford it or
because of other dumb reasons you know
um these companies took something that
was a money printing machine it was a
business that was literally printing
money the television industry there was
nothing wrong with it and they all
decided to throw it away to become
speculative tech companies and start
their own streaming service platforms to
have that to have uh the credit card of
millions of subscribers and you know get
out of uh contract negotiations with
cable service providers and it's like
why and now they're all around
with it again like Star Trek Paramount
uh pulled the plug on Prodigy and
they're trying to license it to other
platforms because they need the money
these aren't decisions that are made
because they don't like you or don't
think that you like your show it's
because they can't survive if they don't
make these decisions Paramount's in
serious trouble I spoke too much trouble
Paramount's in serious trouble they're
all in serious trouble all of them
Disney were losing 500 million dollars a
quarter at one point uh early this year
late last year I mean that even if even
a bohemoth like Disney cannot afford to
lose two billion dollars a year because
I read that uh the CEO of Disney this
morning or yesterday said we may have
made a mistake when we raised prices so
high for Disney uh theme parks
um you know we we were trying to balance
not having an overcrowded place with
accessibility to to everybody but but
with our drive to raise our profit
margin we may have raised the price to
Ohio now I think we're paying the price
for that yeah I spoke to an island and I
was an analyst okay we'll get my words
out and analyst yeah a couple of months
ago though and he was saying that it's
generally considered
by his seat his firm he works for room
um I can't really say what they do we'll
skip over that bit but anyway they do
business analyst of um big movies
business and large companies and he says
um Power might have maybe got back 12
months and they're gonna have to start
making some very difficult decisions
um 12 months well it says the main
problem is they've got certain loans and
certain debt that has to be restructured
roughly this time next year and if
interest rates are still going up the
way they are they're going to have a
real problem and why because they tried
to become a speculative tech company uh
I've heard that they're trying to sell
the Star Trek franchise
oh I got called to liar when I said that
a couple of months ago
I heard it from one of the lawyers in
the conversation because I used to be an
executive at Paramount and I know a lot
of these people and
uh but the Paramount's problem also came
from the fact that they accepted
they accepted a like a 20 billion dollar
financing partnership with a Chinese
company the Chinese company funded
almost none of it and then bailed
so Paramount made all these decisions
thinking that they had 20 million
dollars 20 billion dollars uh and then
had to like they almost went under right
then the number of Times Square One has
almost gone under though it's like
that's the sort of that's their sweet
spot I think yeah yeah well we I used to
joke when we go to a Star Trek movie
about which company owns Paramount this
this movie and it's Gulf westerners who
owns Paramount this week
um but um I Heard every minute long ago
students said that they were
there's some people at Paramount that
really don't like what Seeker Hideout
have done with Star Trek and they keep
going they don't like what they what
secret hideout have done with Star Trek
what Alex kurtzman and the production
have done with Star Trek
um and actually they're about that close
to stay in that the Star Trek Academy
where they were going to cancel it and
so they're going to pull it but then
they got Michelle yo to do section 31
yeah and that was so well received
and it's giving some reason
yeah
Circle A lot of people are angry at
kurtzman
uh
so I think I have to say this politely
one thing I would say this politely uh
I think Discovery is largely great I
think Prodigy is great I think lower
decks is amazing and I think uh strange
I think Picard
I understand the politics involved with
Picard and they were significantly
larger than any executive or the studio
itself so I understand why that was
troubled in the first two seasons and so
well received in the third season uh but
uh which I loved by the way and I think
strange new worlds is great
um I think however that it's poor form
for entertainment to stand on a soapbox
I think that what was great about the
original series is rather than making
speeches all day every day about why
Uhura or Sulu were on the bridge uh or
Chekhov was on the bridge or why you
know women were in positions of power uh
they just had them there yeah you know
you you're you're not going to win
people over by telling them they're
wrong and I think that Star Trek is All
Star Trek is good Trek I believe that
hashtag All Star Trek is good all
travels good trick I'm gonna disagree
with you on that one uh
for someone so it's it's not okay to
on people who love whatever version
of Trek you might not like
um I think that they're trying to
continue the legacy of inclusion
and you know like you you know all of us
getting along and bigotry basically
being dead
uh I think that's fun and great but I
think that there's an amount of not
doing it the right way in the new track
um again because people don't like to be
told they're wrong
and but it's it's easier to get people
to
like an amoeba absorb the good stuff
normalize the things that people were
uncomfortable with for whatever reason
than it is to tell them they're wrong
you will never convert someone you tell
them that who you tell is wrong
there's no point attacking somebody that
it's it's
you just it's kind of the only way to
normalize it is to act like it's normal
and to not try to tell people they're
wrong that's it in my day job I work
with a lot of people with disabilities
and learning disabilities and that's
something we talk about a lot is
normalization we're used to shout you
know these people need they deserve to
be in our community and now we say but
they're not in the community because
they're in homes and everything so why
don't we actually get them in the
community well let's stop shouting about
it let's just do it yeah and that's one
of the things
yeah the last decade is normal isn't it
you know let's have these people
learning disabilities in the community
and people will see it and they will
it'll become normal and that's
um I mean I don't think Star Trek was
ever Supple about its
inclusionistic way of doing it but like
you said before the moments when it
needed to be yeah the black and white
face is the famous one isn't it that was
not remotely yeah um like on the right
side and I'm white on the left on the
right side still genius today it's
brilliant and there's so there are some
yeah there's some terrible the original
series episodes but my God that's not
one of them
um
even in the Next Generation they weren't
subtle at times but like you said though
there's a Russian fella in on in on the
thing during the Cold War and it was
never mentioned ever
um first interracial kiss on American
television probably global television
was on there was um
I mean we just watched the balance of
Terror on Sunday live with our audience
with our fans and one of the things that
was our first live show so there were a
lot of technical problems but uh uh one
of the great things about that episode
is there's this moment where and it's
famous where Styles the Helmsman the
Navigator gets uh uh upset that romulans
look like Vulcans and he immediately
becomes suspicious about Spock and Kirk
turns his chair and he's like you can
keep your bigotry in your cabin and
there's no place on the bridge of the
Enterprise
and that was a very bold statement but
then uh our friends at unplanned Trek
has was an amazing podcast by these guys
out of Tasmania uh Isaac and Andrew uh
one of their questions about the episode
then was where can one leave their
bigotry according to Kirk and it's like
in their cabin yeah
he sits at the door that's fair enough
um I say I
I love slower decks I thought lower
Dexter's probably is one of my favorite
things on TV and I was so surprised at
how great it was but I'm such a big fan
of Rick and Morty that it's like ah
well I've I've done I've got a video
coming out in two days actually which
will be after this will come out
afterwards but I've said well I would
love Stargate to do in the next few
years and there was um I don't know if
you remember there was a Stargate
episode called Wormhole extreme where
um it sort of leaked out that we're the
Stargate existed rubber so I said we
said that it was that guy who um knew
about the program
but he was hilarious he's great yeah
um I just know him from is that guy from
that was in Sex in the City right my
wife
um but I'm just saying they should do a
wormhole extreme animated series if the
Stargate series kicks off and I thought
that was so good idea oh and I got a lot
of comments
that'd be a great idea
it's out of the universe so they love
none of that Canon kicking about stuff
and it could they could make it funny
and if this fans Target franchise kicked
off yeah it's like Prada it's like it's
like Lord X it's a big inside joke for
the fans yeah exactly
um I'm gutted about Prodigy but I
completely understand why it failed and
I say
it's some of the best track on TV I
thought the last step we actually saw
what happened to the Enterprise e at the
end of Prodigy and it's like big things
like that for us for trickies it's like
oh this is glorious
um and there's so much detail in there
but it was a kid's cartoon
where most of the references were 30
years old
shocked it was a Nickelodeon show it
shouldn't have been a Nickelodeon thing
it should have just been a proper
Paramount plus grown-up
sure well they did like that He-Man
Kevin Smith did that He-Man show
um and I'm massive human fan there's
there's supposed to be a live action
movie and if it doesn't get made I might
have to go kick somebody at Netflix wait
who should play He-Man I need to I need
to know this oh they've got a kid I
don't know him for anything I'll Google
it I'll message you tell you later but I
don't I don't know if it's happening
because it was supposed to have happened
by now
and I can't find anything to say whether
it's still happening or not but um
nothing's happening now well no not at
the moment but it was supposed to start
filming the start of the year but maybe
they've just delayed it because of
what's going on but
um
but um yeah it's it's this young guy I
don't know who I don't know him from
anything else but um I would just I just
love it I hated the Kevin Smith cartoon
but I still watched it but um but they
just did that they put on Netflix I'm
it's only my generation watching that no
kids was watching that yeah
um but it's still about did decent views
so I got another Series so
um even though Kevin Smith gets yelled
at occasionally for that as well but
such a shame
um but I said I I only didn't like
Discovery because I thought and this is
Alex kurtzman's fault and I will blame
him for it
um he brought Too Much from the JJ
Abrams stuffing so like the look of the
Klingons and things like this was all
dragged from the JJ Abrams movies
uh which he wrote and helped and and
that's because he helped he had a hand
in creating this yeah
um and it just it ruined the show for me
in the first two seasons third season
onwards it got loads better you know
that's the thing that that will never
bother me like if you want to advance
the I actually was
um
I'm not gonna go all the way and say I'm
a big fan of the discovery Klingons from
season one discovery
uh but I I am a fan of
unsoftening the edges of Klingons
because the Klingons are always
introduced in each series as these
monstrously aggressive and then
you know they're played by short actors
and they whenever there's a fight
between Klingons and humans the humans
always win like fist fights you know
Cisco's always punching out some giant
going on it's like
we're reality like there's a lot of
jabber about how scary they are but
they're not actually scary so I think
them trying to make them these monsters
um was really exciting for me they
didn't obviously it didn't they didn't
carry it through because it got all
weird but um
uh just the idea that Klingons are these
horrible
powerful powerful aggressive monsters
um who are intelligent but you know
honor bound and warlike and Unstoppable
ones that because their honors says they
can't they can't blah blah blah
um I like that
I don't think it's wrong to experiment
uh with adjusting
the tropes and the Canon
because with each successive show or
movie you are actually and I mean we
just talked about this like no kid
understands the references from Prodigy
because they're all 30 years old uh the
references are all 30 years old
um
with each successive show or movie
there's another whole section of
demographics that are entering the
fandom who you also have to
you know
play to because if you don't you're
gonna fail and you're not gonna tell me
that explanation movies over and over
and over and over again uh they would
have failed the last Nemesis was the
biggest bomb
it wasn't good though I mean
Insurrection was the worst one out of
things it was not good and when we're
coming off first Contact which is
I nearly said it was mine but it's
definitely the best of those Star Treks
I like Generations the best first
Contact
yeah I do like bits of generations uh
interaction seemed like a TV movie
almost
seemed like an episode of Star Trek yeah
it's it seemed like they were I don't
quite know what they were trying to do
with it but yeah I think it wouldn't
even be a particularly good episode of
Star Trek and that's the problem it was
trying to I don't know it just it missed
on many areas the remote control you
know when the joystick comes out he
starts flying the Enterprise
remote control and it's like
what the f is that
I'm through running from these bastards
yeah I'm just like oh my god
um and I think it's because like when
data turns around and goes oh when
the um the you know the um sorcer sex
discussion that was so well received
they were like oh well we can we can
have thrown a couple of swear words now
but then when I could do it we're just
like
um and I'm not sure how that joystick is
controlling the Enterprise in
three-dimensional space
um it starts it's not meteor
um but um but yeah it's it's just
annoying me but I I love the JJ Abrams
movies they're just not Star Trek to me
if I just don't think of them as Star
Trek I can really enjoy enjoyable movies
yes yeah great movies but they're just
not Star Trek
[Music]
um
uh I get like uh part of me hates the
alternate timeline stuff part of me is
like all right I get it they didn't want
to with fandom
they didn't want like Canon lovers to
get all up in a tizzy
um
you know and the first 15 minutes of JJ
Star Trek one
the Kelvin battle with the Romulan
mining ship uh and the and Kirk's birth
um
is some of the not just the best Star
Trek I've ever seen it's some of the
best movie making I've ever seen it's
it's an amazing story bring your
girlfriend to a movie theater who
doesn't like Star Trek and just then her
to tear up in the first 15 minutes
because of how intense and Incredibly
well constructed that storytelling was
and I know how hard it was for them to
pull that sequence together they had
many many variations on it and it was
not what was in the script uh
um
but I mean that's it's remarkable
filmmaking and that in and of itself
makes the JJ Abrams Star Trek A-Okay in
my book Because all three of them have
got bits clearly they cared yeah my only
I say I do have a couple of issues in
movies in that um I think it's quite
impressive that they made
um
crap I've got his name British actually
played Khan
I do know his name I'll Cumberbatch
Benedict cumber to make Benedict
Cumberbatch was not British
to make then you get complex with like a
bad actor that's quite impressive and he
he wasn't great in that I have a theory
about that I have a theory that he was
not particularly interested in some of
these big giant movies
I was super interested in the paychecks
um very possible
sometimes if the contractor is I know
some actors they say to okay I want to
do this project to the studio because
the studio though we yes we will fund
that we would love to do that but you
have you don't have to do yeah yeah
I I've heard that before but um it's a
real thing one for me one for them yeah
even in the last film which I actually
didn't like particularly I love the
scene where they're coming in and
they're like and they play the music and
they're destroy nothing and there's some
visually it was stunning
um there's something I love out of all
of them but that's a Star Trek film for
me the motion picture a bit slow I still
love it but it was a bit slow I actually
just re-watched it a week or two ago
it's it's very slow but it's beautiful
yeah oh it's beautifully made
um but I mean it deserved every award it
got
um Wrath of Khan is one of the greatest
movies ever made yes I agree it's 100
the Search for Spock has great but there
are bits a week the um the Voyage Home
is the stupidest plot for a film I think
of and it just worked it was yeah it
worked we all love humpback whales yep
and then they go find God
that was that had good bits and five
I I had a good bit the opening sequence
at Yosemite and stuff I thought that was
a great scene amazing their friendship
uh all that stuff uh the beans the
climbing El Capitan
um I I get again I I mentioned it
earlier
um we're good friends with uh a podcast
called unplanned Trek yeah I'm not a
Tasmanian yeah and they do
for their patreon members they are doing
a minute by minute in-depth analysis of
Star Trek 5 the final frontier
uh every every week and a new episode
comes out and I've done a number of them
with them and it is incredibly funny it
is so fun and Star Trek 5 is one of
those movies where it's like it's really
it's bad
but it's so good that's the movie where
Kirk says I need my pain which is quite
possibly the best kirkline
the sequence with um with McCoy when
he's doing his things and and it's it's
genuinely upsetting to watch yeah it's
ruined by finding God but even the
finding God sequence was actually yeah
it was good yeah what does God need with
a Starship yeah it's glorious
um going through the Great Barrier I'm
like that's like more the physics on
that Let's ignore the stupidity of the
center of the Galaxy yeah it works and
whatever we've now learned it's massive
black holes but we'll uh we'll we'll
pretend that but then Undiscovered
Country for me is is easily my favorite
Star Trek movie but because and that's
got bad hands down for me as well number
one yeah sometimes nostalgic but the
Undiscovered Country is a mind when I
was in college I wrote a comic book a
graphic novel a series of comic books uh
uh
called civvies it was basically lower
decks that's gonna say is this it was
for the civilian contractors who worked
on the Enterprise Aid during the events
of Star Trek six
Star Trek six was going on
around these stories that I was writing
and I'd like hand Illustrated them all
and yeah I'm obsessed with Star Trek six
I saw that movie probably 60 times in
the movie theater I snuck out of school
to go and watch it that's out in the
cinema on my own
um in my school time hoping that nobody
would notice because I've got 13 or 14.
yeah my
ugly brown and yellow shirt so I stood
out like a sore thumb as well one other
bloke in the cinema screen in the cinema
um
the battle scene at the end just blew my
mind it's um the whole thing when
they're at in the prison
um I'll Target that explosion in fire
yeah oh it's repente or something like I
can never say I literally watched this
one two days ago
thank you
um that is a bit boring it goes on a bit
um yeah and when he kisses what's her
face the uh
I want to say
what is your name Ayman
come on Iman yeah
uh very pretty
um
they did acknowledge it by bones leaning
over me like what is with you anyway
yeah I mean as a I can't believe I
kissed you must have been the greatest
appearance of your life
kill him he's the one yeah yeah but the
way William Shatner sort of perceived as
a bit of a egomaniac that's a great
scene where he's you know poke fun at
himself and um and I'm a big Bill
Shatner fan I I Adore the man
um son's name is Tiberius like really
yeah
it's like Shannon who's who who's your
favorite Captain Kirk uh yeah but what
about it's like no Kirk did it first
Kirk if not for Kirk none of this
would exist
well what do you think about the new
Kirk on strange new Wilson
you know uh at first I was like when he
showed up in that uh last episode of the
first season I was like
I don't
I don't understand what they're doing
here I don't want to be come out on this
negative but I don't understand the
choice
um watching this second season where uh
he and she go to Toronto
I was like okay I get it more like I get
it
yeah it was a better episode it was a
better episode and also unfortunately
like
um this actor playing Kirk whose name
I'm forgetting right now
um just known as Vampire Diaries guy
there you go yeah
uh when he went toe-to-toe with Anson
Mount
I was like oh no Anson would murder you
in a fist fight I think
he clearly has You by 50 pounds like
the guy Anson looks like he's 6'4 and
Kirk actor looks mostly half
yeah like two feet of hair
um but it just he looked like a kid
standing up to to Anson and I was like
oh this is not Kirk like Kirk can't seem
like a kid he's got to seem like an
authority and that's why I like Chris
Pine so much
um yes nobody even considered uh his
physical size uh in his performance he
was just he carried that weight of it's
not Carissa Kirk is supposed to be
charismatic confidence you know yeah
almost like to the point of ego
um centrisism but like not too far over
the line like that's the wonderful thing
about Kirk as a character is he sways
back and forth between self-doubt and
overconfidence uh and that balance is
something that the character maintains
uh somehow through the help of his
friends bones and Spock
um and uh
it's never been that's never been
repeated everyone loves Picard sure
everyone loves Picard Picard is like
he is the ethical center of the universe
he is the moral compass that we've all
been waiting for he does everything
right
yeah uh yeah I I like the way they did
Picard in that it wasn't he never
doubted himself there wasn't that
confidence thing maybe but
he was the captain he was alone you know
and they yeah he was an island
so that means he couldn't he wore that
burden hard well he had to be separate
yeah
um but I didn't know that I won't keep
him much longer it's already over an
hour and I know we could talk about this
till
so
um
Picard season three yeah
it's
the first time in a while I've got up on
a month because it came out Thursday
here
um so Thursday morning wait wait wait
wait wait you're only seeing it now no
no God I don't know when it came out so
um it came out um it came out the day
after it came out in America I see I see
what you're saying okay so
um so I it was the it's this only Star
Trek show out of the new track
that I've got up early
to watch before I go to work sort of
thing
um I've actually
uh Star Trek uh Picard season three is
the first Star Trek where Erica was like
are we gonna go watch it can we want are
we watching it tonight
yeah it's they got she wanted to see the
next episode every time which to me was
like oh thank God finally we've got it
finally yeah we put our hooks in her and
now she's ours but um I have to admit
that I've I've watched it since with a
bit a bit more critically
I didn't enjoy it as much
I mean you know second viewings always
do yeah I think once I took out the
Nostalgia and the excitement
yeah there's quite a lot of mistakes in
it that were irritating
um that I kept noticing and I hated that
they called the Titan the Enterprise at
the end
I hate it I know I thought they were
gonna call it the Picard yeah
I think they let that rumor slip out on
purpose that they were going to call it
the Picard because they wanted to be a
surprise because they'd ruined all the
other surprises it should not have been
the Enterprise it should have been the
Picard
no
um we go from the you know the the
Odyssey class which is a stunning ship
um to that little Titan I'm like yeah
but it's the underdog
every time it goes somewhere it's
overmatched and yet they so they have to
out think you know there's one of my
favorite sayings ever is
um World War II was one with British
brains American Brawn and Russian blood
and the British brains portion of it is
my favorite and I've always thought
though
if they'd have done another SGA sg1 and
SGA I know Joe Flanagan said they were
very different shows
I'll discuss that with him they weren't
they were very similar in lots and lots
of ways
um the formula the way the form the way
they were set up sort of thing SGU was
completely different in every single way
they always take a minute the best shows
take a minute to get on their feet
uh season three is usually when they
hone it in did you just saying that you
liked Han Solo the the movie they did
you're the only one I loved it you're on
your own on that one it was charismatic
it was fun
I liked it
tell you that I watched your recent
video
about Stargate and you were talking with
about the pop cast guys I want Amazon to
work well because one I'm always going
to be an Amazon Prime member because I
I order a lot of stuff from Amazon
email I was asking if you're a um
business I do I go oh you're a business
would you like a business account
because no I don't buy a lot of crap
from you